hey what's up Whitney how great thanks
for doing my podcast yeah how are you
doing it's awesome
um I don't mind if I slam the room first
before we oh please no let's go well we
started or no we've started we're
rolling yes
Whitney thanks for having me I didn't
know you ran a charter school
I feel a little creepy sitting here in
front of the uh the craft the craft that
I've been this is a Montessori School
everybody pick out an animal that
represents you go ahead this is a
therapist's office a child therapist
office yeah these chairs are pretty low
so we're picking we're figuring out what
you're picking up to diagnose you you've
so far picked up a box of cigarettes and
nothing else
there we go we're Dinosaurs the opaque
dinosaurs that's perfect we're comedians
that do comedy live we are dinosaurs I
feel I've never felt older I've got some
uh babies downstairs blood for you to
drink oh really you can take uh 10 years
off your age right now from a smoothie I
have in the freezer you know I have a
vitamin joke do you think that's like
already like so old that it's like
people are like what is that I'd love to
hear about it okay a vitamin I've you
know I figured I talk about you know
multivitamins you know as an old man and
everything like that I could see the
crowd turned off they rolled their eyes
that's like Centrum Silver can Rogan hey
can I send some silver joke it's a
multivitamin for men but hey like like
here's the problem with your your
vitamins like I literally my gag reflex
is so strong from auditioning in
Hollywood I guess I I cannot swallow I
am at the point where all these vitamins
was like I open them and put the powder
in a water I understand because when I
take a NyQuil I'm gonna put it like I
can't you make it more of a supplement I
can't even get a z-quil down at this
point my gag reflex yeah I don't ask it
how's your sleep are you sleeping I've
never slept a day in my life what's it
like I have the problem same thing too
but that's what everybody who uh you
know if you have any kind of problem
they always diagnose sleep and water
well let me say I'm drinking enough
water a couple things how was your sleep
but here's all they care about well now
they make science bracelets that tell
you how you slept oh really right you
know like what band like stuff like that
they now but let me let me does that
explain the balloons we'll be right back
the white balloon that
um what's your balloon do just came in
from China I don't uh well no remember
the Chinese white balloon yeah that's
what I'm talking about oh good see every
time something happens what other
balloon is there another balloon now
carowind balloons and I live in L.A
people are heroin balloon fentanyl mules
balloon could have my tits you could
have been talking about my tits I
apologize I'm talking about the balloons
that were the Chinese balloon that uh
Elon Musk travels in I don't know well I
said that um I don't know what that
balloon was doing but my phone Flash the
man for Panda Express and you can see
the outrage in the young crowd
I don't know I looked at it it was like
looking in the mirror when I wake up and
the morning with no makeup on
um
that balloon looks like half my friends
without makeup on so I got confused I
thought it was like I thought it was uh
it's yesterday's news that's all I know
look everyone's moved past I'm
fascinated by that because it's like I
whenever news happens for the past like
15 years I always go like what's Dave's
joke like I remember seeing you I'm like
such a stalker of yours I remember
remember when there was the snow in in
the Denver Airport oh yeah this is like
10 years ago you were in Caroline's and
I was at Gotham or some shit
um uh in the green room with surrounded
by the Voss water no I would say Comics
remember comics with an X yes I remember
going in the green room and seeing Voss
water and being like well this club
won't be around long and I was like
headlining it and uh you were at
Caroline's in between my shows I would
run to see you Caroline's and um I just
was like how does he have 45 minutes on
something that happened two days ago
um and you would write in these
composition notebooks like I saw like
you would you know really I never
considered myself a notebook guy I was
more of a uh you know those yellow pads
that was my name for a while yellow pad
this is the only way yeah that's that's
what I like this is what I do because
you can rip them and make that like
throwing it no get rid of it I literally
think about it and go like when I'm
found dead alone in my house because
I've fallen down this flight of stairs
because I'm not meant to live in a home
I'm meant to live in a tiny apartment
they'll know where my jokes are because
it'll be yellow yeah the yellow people
don't know like that that this isn't my
Suicide no these are my jokes the
suicide note is like five I the yellow
legal pad I like that and because I
think there's something I know this is
going to sound annoying to the people
listening there's something kind of that
makes me feel like this is a legitimate
job yeah that's right because it's a
legal path like you're taking a
deposition look it's literally like yeah
I totally it's like teen joke dick joke
the vaccine is a scam and then I'm like
and I feel like a secretary who has a
legitimate job and when it sucks you get
to rip it up and like oh it makes a lot
of noise everybody's like what's going
on and then after I wrote five scribbles
on the first page
that's it oh there's something oh yeah
yeah it's then empty no Then I then I go
back to drawing usually this is my
current joke like you really are
hardcore with the jokes I love it but I
don't put it I only started writing them
in documents to date them because I'm so
afraid someone's gonna accuse me of
stealing jokes and then I'll go oh no
it's dated so I do send now right every
new joke at the end of the day I write
it date it email it to myself oh that's
a great idea because I remember like
Fortune theme store dear dear friend we
were both doing a joke about
um
Red Rover Red Rover you know yeah yeah
that how dangerous like it was some like
some joke about like the last thing I
did about um when people like cell
phones are so dangerous for kids like we
played Red Rover yeah yeah and you know
whatever and she texted me and was like
I'm doing a Red Rover joke and it was so
chill it wasn't like like we were like
I'm doing one you're doing one how long
what's yours like we had the most adult
thing about it and I was like oh I think
we could both keep doing them ours are
so different sure but if someone was
like I've been I can go you can have it
I never like please but I just want you
to know right this email I did have it
before and I would never steal a joke
that's my I get fanatical about joke
checking I'll call up all the all the
people I know who are joke writers and
I'm like have you heard this have you
heard anyone do this have you heard
anything like it and then I'll have like
you know when you start watching
specials then you got to go re-watch
them again to make sure you're not doing
someone's joke so it's like it's an
endless loop in your head it's almost
like this like this like just constant
like I I don't know I don't know you
know and it's like I think the way you
do it is good where you you write it you
date it to yourself and then you know
that you have a record of the joke and
also like Dave you realize like any time
any comic thinks of something funny we
all go
Dave must have done this already right
we literally go oh that's not we call
each other going like did we steal this
from Dave because it's too funny is
there a left turn in it
but it's like is there a clown at the
end yeah exactly but I think it's like I
think I'm the more jokes you think of I
guess the more paranoid you get and I
also think my self-esteem it's so funny
how low you it reveals how low your
self-esteem is in that moment because
you're like I just thought of something
hilarious I must have stolen It Well by
accident do you want the great news
please there's a place where you don't
have to think like that at all it's
called Tick Tock just lip sync someone
else's act and a crew followers and then
just basically chin up go hey I'm
awesome you know if you talk about my
biological clock one more time I will
call HR last night at 3 30 19 a.m I
wrote this none of us have any time
anymore from all the time we're saving
wait none of us having time anymore
we're uh like we're slammed from all
these time-saving apps like has anyone
saved time using Amazon by the time you
order it and complain about it it's been
six hours like you've actually ordering
from Amazon I actually lose four hours
complaining and feeling guilty about the
driver who has to shit in the bag you
know what I'm saying so it's like that's
a great that's a great uh see for me
it's always like the the actual thought
uh thought process is great it's like
the the apps do they really save time
and they really they really don't so
right there whenever we get our food
delivered we get our groceries delivered
we we uh uh we don't have to call and
wait to buy a plane ticket anymore we do
it all online we have auto pay yes and
we're the busiest we've ever been
yet I have 50 apps on my phone that are
promising to save me time with running
errands sure I totally I totally so then
I go there's like a seed of a bit there
like the great irony for sure that's
like the the the dating app experience
right I'm not on any of those but for
people it's like you know to meet to
meet a hundred losers do you know how
many nights that I have to be out it's
like I can meet them all in one like
once One swipe so that's the uh that's
how it works this show is brought to you
by betterhelp if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge
discover your potential with better help
so I've it's like going to the gym for
your brain right so we never say
you know oh I've been going to the gym
for 10 years so now I never have to go
again
you know you never you don't think that
way so it's like I always come out of it
saving time because I'm not wasting a
bunch of time worrying about things I
can't control so that's that's all idea
of therapy it's just the idea of like
we're actually going to save you time
let's by releasing a lot of stuff here
so that you don't waste a bunch of time
doing things driven by shame guilt uh
don't say yes to things that you should
be saying no to so I think the only
thing I'll say is me going I go to
therapy first and foremost because it
frees up time that I would otherwise be
wasting worrying about things I can't
control if visit betterhelp.com Whitney
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help atlp.com Whitney can
I do a quick surprise for you yeah sure
I hate surprises but sure I know you
don't this is my surprise David tell I
just want to make him laugh that I don't
care if you've already made me laugh so
much all I want to do is make him like
my catheter is falling out several times
while I was on your pocket what is the
name of the podcast by the way this is
called the Insomniac so Joan Dangerfield
the gray Joan Dangerfield is joining us
David
what's up how are you
where are you
she lives in my computer now what's
going on where are you headed oh you're
in this house I think are you it's a big
house there's two time zones she's in my
basement that's right
Jonah you coming by the podcast
I'm kidnapping Joan next weekend I'm
taking her to Austin for the opening of
Joe's Club oh that's gonna be great how
exciting is that Isn't that cool so yeah
I can't believe you're taking me with me
by the way I can't believe I thought you
were calling to Camp to Kansas
how do you have lower self-esteem than
me it's shocking so can I ask you the
quick quickest thing ever so yes so yes
so can you see so Rodney I wanted to
talk through how Rodney on his sets what
all of the um numbers and letters mean
am I allowed to do that real quick or
you have to go talk to a lawyer um you
are and sue someone for stealing his
stuff or
no it's fine I can answer I can't answer
so could you walk us through
unhappy tip this is I need to see a
little more of it sorry
64th so the upper left-hand corner where
it says 64 of Rodney Dangerfield's sets
should I just smash this open and pull
it out
64th yeah that's just 64th um spot he
used to call him spot
but I'm Johnny Carson and
I can't collect anybody he does page
numbers one and looks like one and two
we go in the wrong direction as far as
I'm gonna stand up
please and the second page sorry okay
can you see me this is like yeah I'm the
worst person sorry this is why Joe Rogan
got 300 million dollars and why I'm
blowing um Better Health yeah I'll hold
it you can so so no don't cover days
sorry
so this means
64th Tonight Show
um right the the black check mark and
the red check mark next to a joke
means that he got Applause which meant
hold on hold on Wow can I make sure I'm
miking you one second oh so this is his
like um yes after after the set so he'd
write the set out and then afterwards
he'd go backstage
and if he got laughter he got a black
check mark red meant Applause
um actually he didn't do the check mark
right after the show he did
it according of the sport listen to the
recording of the show
and which is the jokes is this blue
writing is that his handwriting
oh wow would actually switch pens so
that the punch line was uh in bold oh
okay that's what he did with like a
Sharpie like a much thicker pan so the
the blue handwriting that's that M's you
know doing the setup for the joke the
blue is the setup in the uh and the
punch line is in the bolt oh see I do I
wow that's interesting and then what
does the a mean the Applause oh Applause
I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah hey sorry I was
just trying to put my computer and do
not disturb we're having an incredible
comedy history moment and the fucking
but this is I'm sorry Whitney but uh for
a Tonight Show set he would tell I would
say plus 50 jokes because I just did a
uh I was I was someone asked me to do a
documentary be a part of a documentary
on Rodney and we got to look at his
notes Rick Rubin okay cool yeah Rick
Rubin and I thought it was really cool
and way overdue because Rodney is that
there was no one like him but I think
Rick
how he set it up but when you when you
see how many jokes per minute that uh
Rodney would do because the setups the
setups were brief but they totally it
was just like there was no fat on a joke
zero fat zero fat and that is like in
today's Times where you like you're
eating a pan of fat like it's it's
pretty amazing okay
really
that's the same phrase I don't know if
that's like a common comedy thing or or
not wow that makes me feel good because
I think we we talk that way too yeah no
fat and
some people called him like uh a master
editor because he wanted the joke to be
as short as possible
um but that's because he thought
everyone had a short attention span like
he did he wanted to get to it really
quick that's always what um Howard Stern
would say and then for all of you that
think I have ADD and I cut people off
and stuff Howard Stern would say if I'm
bored that means the audience has been
bored oh right interesting so well
Howard's also a master so just cut if
you need to interrupt people do it
because I I'm looking at Paul McCartney
and I'm it's four in the morning or
whatever I'm if I'm bored the person
with four jobs and three kids in the
back seat is already bored so it's like
yeah yeah
I'm also very respectful of other
people's time like he wanted his book
his the biggest compliment about his
autobiography that he got from a reader
was that they read it in in one night
really it's glad yeah there was glad no
self-indulgence and I think that that
Comics who worked
for lack of a better word blue collar
jobs know how little time most people
have
so so yeah so I've worked in service
yeah you they don't have a lot of time
to listen to their comedy in this
self-indulgent shit where we're going on
stage where people that have four jobs
are like I need to laugh right now this
is medicine I'm coming here to get
medicine yeah and I I have a babysitter
that that I have to pay overtime if you
don't get these jokes to me faster it's
like it's like Rodney it's like fast
food you know we're service people you
know I hate it when I have to wait an
hour for my mistake to come to my table
I'm like where's my I have to get home
and comedians we're kind of doing that
we're like you know well the other thing
I really liked about I think that's all
it's true is like when you can see from
both sides of the uh experience but with
Rodney that they there's a lot of great
that I like about Rodney but one of them
is that he's super relatable yet he
really was never a crowd guy he was
never like I'm gonna jump in the crowd
and talk to everybody he he basically
did his job you know oh he was up there
doing doing the jokes and the crowd was
there to listen and I know when he
started it was not like it is today so
these were really rough and tumble like
halls and like bars and whatever he
played he probably couldn't see the
crowd through this opaque's stroke yeah
and they're drinking that back then they
started drinking at 11 A.M right and
they really span was they were gonna and
the crowd would tell you if you if they
didn't like it they they were not like
basically I'll get it all out on them
they would tell you right that you suck
at all the comedian has 10 security
guards and because they have Lyme
disease we're not allowed to throw shit
out there right you know what I'm saying
so it's like well that's very cool can
you tell us Joan and we can cut this out
if it's too personal
um about him in parking lots people
being aggressive with him see I can get
beat up if they didn't like his jokes
yeah he was careful even like when he
was working Vegas if if the audience was
crowding around him
expected to shake it under something he
wouldn't do that because he was afraid
they were going to pull him down and
then punch him because that would remind
him back of the old days right when
there used to be like
um Hooligans or whatever you want to
call them like comedy shows in the olden
days because we call them feature Acts
yeah because you know sometimes he was
performing with strippers and dog acts
and and you know all kinds of things
like that back when he was first getting
started and he did get punched out a few
times he he told me about one particular
parking lot incident where he he then
went to the mirror to see if you know uh
how he thought that he could even go on
um
a lot of times the security guards
punching him out
um why I don't know he thought it was
because maybe he didn't do a good enough
job in your experience do you think
because I think now we're going oh
violence against comedians is like new
we saw Chris rocket punch in the face no
one stood up as we watched our friend
get assaulted no one in Hollywood stood
up
um uh not not sure at all but also in
Jim Jefferies getting punched in the
face in uh Australia like even if you
don't like someone's joke Caparulo it um
her most a comedy magic club so is is I
think we're now going people are going
oh all of a sudden it's dangerous to be
a stand-up comedian I think it's safe to
say it's
always
physically
dangerous and Ronnie is like the first
thing you have to do was be likable
um you know that that was more important
than even being funny you've got to be
likable when you're on stage so he was
very conscientious about that like as in
please don't kill so that you don't so
that you don't kill me he's another
that's right here's another here's
another great thing about Rodney because
you you remember his earlier act when he
was more of an esoteric he didn't have
the strong punch lines he didn't have
these great these great basically set up
kill move on set up kill where he was
more rambling and you know with his look
where he's with sweat and all that kind
of stuff it really looked like he was uh
you know in in the hole as I call it but
that was his old act that was I think I
saw him on it was like at Sullivan or
Jack Parr or something like that and
then when you see how he basically
looked at that and said this isn't
working and he went back and he
basically retooled his whole thing and
turned it into this I like to call it
like a punchline machine I mean the
guy's a factory of jokes and like he
wouldn't give him a chance to even like
breathe so I was like that's amazing
that he looked at what he was doing and
said like it is me it's not the crowd
and this is not working and I'm gonna
like basically retool what I do
reimagine it whatever they call it
nowadays and and it turned into like
ultimate success and then we all also
because when when Dave came in today you
got a chair because this is really like
oh it's like Daddy Daughter day over
here
no I'm gonna bring a chair over here
um behind the curtain when Rodney was
performing in
and I wish you this is why men have
money and women don't in this business
because I I if I had self-esteem I would
have just said can you come by but I
wouldn't you know now I'm on like like
Boingo Wireless is sabotaging this
conversation
um Wi-Fi no no I wanna I I want to be on
the television oh but don't let me do it
don't don't let them know that Byron
Allen's texting me we were two grad
students watching stuff on your laptop
there she is
honestly
oh
shit oh my god get that dog in here hold
on hold on hold on get your mom's asses
quick hold on let's read let's reiment
Dave just spilled his coffee on my
carpet now I can put it on eBay this is
my retirement plan Dave don't touch it
don't clean it up uh just another brown
spot everything we do
you have reminded me
up can you hear me yeah we can
I need to um sit backstage when Rodney
was performing in this uh we were
together like 20 21 years as a matter of
fact but
um what would happen is I noticed that
there was a pattern he would get a laugh
every three to four seconds wow that is
in a one hour show and I noticed that
yeah there was a really to it there was
everything and I I don't know how you
judge when the exact piece of a second
would be to start his next joke but he
had that down to such a science and and
uh you know so repetitive that when we
would record one show and then listen to
a recording of the other you could
practically synchronize them together as
if it was just one record wow that's
that's amazing yeah I wish I had that
Focus
John I don't know man
each time really
at the same moment he was actually out
there like a robot really with
the part like I don't know how you guys
can tell a joke with the scene
enthusiasm and and I can't I really
can't
did you hear that Whitney
she was saying that like from one from
one person when women talk from one from
one show to the when she would listen
backstage from one show to the next that
he he basically was getting a laugh
every three seconds right and then the
next show yeah three to four seconds and
then on the next show it would be he
wouldn't switch up the order or anything
like that just to make it like a little
different he would just basically lock
in again right and go and go through it
see see he was trying to perfect the
performance I'm I don't have that kind
of I don't have that follow through and
I definitely don't have that like uh I
guess you could say that thing because
myself I can't wait to change the joke
he'll commit he well he I'm like well
look I mean I'm big on the way you do
anything is the way you do everything he
committed to a woman he commits to
making a joke perfect I'm not even
kidding you know I have a hard time I
get bored of as soon as a joke starts
killing I get bored of it as soon as
someone falls in love with me I'm bored
of them you know I'm just gonna be
honest here you know I think it's like
you know Rodney
um also I think comedians like you know
our attention spans because we're on
social media our attention spans for we
can't even stay in love with our own
jokes and the audience is like why you
know I I'm just had a situation this
past weekend where I gave audience an
audience a bunch of undercooked jokes
because I was bored of being perfect and
I'm like my job as an Entertainer isn't
for you guys to watch me stay interested
in what I'm doing is my job to deliver a
fully cooked I don't get to experience
like do you get to go to a restaurant
and say
there's a little bit of self-indulgence
but I also think audiences now want to
see our process it's almost like it's
more interesting now to see us fail and
see us work things out but I think one
of the biggest questions I have for you
besides the millions that I have because
we're past life like twins or whatever
um is that um we're lesbians guys I'm
coming out as gay
um this is this is my girlfriend
um what do you need baby no I wanted to
mop up that don't please don't please
don't maybe this overpriced water will
help
can I I uh hold on just go ahead finish
your thoughts no but I but it involves
you oh there's a lot of paper towels up
there so just so you know the greatest
comedians in the world
they if they spill something they clean
it up like David tell is right now
trying to clean up a spill I'm begging
him to stop cleaning it up I'm heading
to that train wreck I'm gonna send this
carpet to the Lucille Ball comedy Museum
in Buffalo I hate this anyway dear hold
on but but Dave but here's the thing can
I just say as a as a fan of Rodney is
that he his jokes and joke you know the
jokes are jokes people look at that part
but there's also the in-betweens and as
a comic he really you really like um you
really love love like when the guy's
like you know like uh you know the uh
dramatic pause and stuff like that and
when he would use the uh you know his
catchphrase which is awesome I talk
about catchphrases now on stage but the
uh the the the right yours is Jaeger uh
well yeah we all we all think we we hit
goal with our stuff but that one says it
all and it's like the crowd's waiting
for it and he kind of like would like
you know like give it to them it's
almost like a dessert
here's what you came to hear you know
but they don't respect us who for real
Rodney made me understand this and I
realized that this weekend in general
well people don't like jokes the way
they used to like jokes people love
repeatable jokes I remember all these
people he's I grew up on Long Island
after Rodney would like appear everybody
would be like at wherever I worked you
know I worked in shipping receiving uh
people would be like hey you know they
try and redo his jokes and you know
retell them and people love that they
felt like you know he he you know they
all were doing his jokes so like that's
not in today's Times like people don't
do that with jokes but I remember seeing
Chris Rock
was this was Maybe This was um uh
seven years ago
um back when Hollywood pretended they'd
protect him if he got attacked uh
publicly I'm on stage
um and uh he was at the comedy store and
he was working on new material
and he's Chris Rock so he'd be like
sorry guys I'm late I can't like you
know I'm trying to get my jokes together
the printer didn't work and people would
start and then the audience started
laughing he's like
and he went stop laughing yeah that
wasn't a joke he was like please stop
laughing
because how am I supposed to and he I'm
paraphrasing the great Chris Rock
um but he said something like please
don't laugh if it's not funny
just because I'm Chris Rock basically in
parentheses he wanted to deserve it
Chris puts in the time he really does
the work you know on the material
because I've seen it at the comedy
seller in New York I've seen him like
get in there and really dig and try and
try and find where it's supposed to go
but I feel a little bit depressed as a
comedian when you start to get paranoid
of you guys know I'm funny you know I
can deliver is this a pavlovian reaction
if I was if it was eight you know 1985
and I was watching Rodney Dangerfield
and he comes out and he goes I'm so
desperate to laugh I know this he's
going to deliver so hard but it's the
comic you're going please don't give me
anything I don't deserve because then
I'm going to Plateau as a comic and I
always want to go be hard on me and I
think this past weekend I started going
feeling I think it's a comic I'm getting
some laughs that I don't deserve just
because you guys know I have a history
of being funny yeah and I'm worried it's
gonna make me less funny you're you're
turning the resistance down on my
exercise size bike or whatever that
means that's why I go on late
on the show because it's the hardest
they've already heard probably the same
present premise like 30 different ways
by the time I get up there so it's
harder it also like is uh I guess I'm
better I'm better I'm better at that
point you know I'm seeing I don't want
to bump anybody I'm seeing a lot of
comics that I uh uh
love and admire get Plateau as artists
because there's famous and they're they
their fans come to see them yeah and and
uh they're
um it makes you atrophy like so I'm
finding that I'm having to create
adversity
for to get better because I'm worried
that I'm coasting on my past
achievements I'm just curious if Rodney
ever got frustrated
can I tell you something about like
um if we were
um in a small town you know someplace
where
um you know maybe famous people didn't
appear very often and run and go to a
local comedy club the crowd would just
go so nuts you didn't have to say
anything and you're right he didn't like
that which is why he would try out
material at clubs that are used to
seeing famous Comics like the ones that
are they're locally you know in La you
would go there all the time to try out
material because you wouldn't trust an
audience that that it was just reacting
to uh who he is
um and and at the local places here
where they're used to seeing you know
David Talent well not I'm curious when
you go to like the Hermosa Beach
he never told the joke on The Tonight
Show or any place elsewhere they were
recording unless it had been tried out
and killed sure at it you know again I
this is where I go back to how a class
was more important to him after a joke
um gets a lot because that that's like
extra proof to him yeah I'm more I'm I'm
worried that comedians were so afraid of
coming off polished and corny and like
trying too hard that it's kind of
turning more into a bravery contest of
like I'm gonna I'm gonna do a I'm gonna
open with a joke I've never told before
and if it bombs like like I at least I
was Brave I think that I find myself
doing this I find myself going like I'm
just gonna out myself I'm gonna go I'd
rather Neil Brennan think I'm brave than
make this whole crowd laugh like I think
some
but I think it's like who's our
allegiance to it's like the uh like I
think that right now comics in a way
like I find myself trying to impress
other comics with How brave with how
how hard like how deep a hole I I can
dig myself into and get out of it
instead of just going these people paid
and I'm gonna give them the burgers they
ordered at McDonald's I'm you know so
I'm going let you know I'm gonna dig a
hole you guys know I can make you laugh
you know it's like McDonald's it's like
McDonald's saying we know you came here
for burgers
but I'm gonna show you
but Rodney would have probably been
do you think Rodney would have been
disgusted by the fact that comedians are
going on stage going what else is
happening and just go
in fact you didn't like the storytelling
go along you know to get to the sunshine
and all that he didn't have the patience
for it
um but back to being naturally funny and
saying something off the cuff that just
killed you I mean
um I told you about what Rodney said
um was not the main circuit of the first
words he spoke after
um you know being in a coma for
something like I think it was 11 days
the doctors came in to ask him
um a question and they were speaking
really loudly they weren't sure if he
was going to respond or not and the lung
doctor said um you know Rodney have you
been coughing up much lately and Rodney
said last week 500 bucks for all more
just like that now he's
compared that yes
happy to be alive right and look at that
delivered just like that I mean
I almost fell off my chair he just cried
the brain surgery they didn't know would
he be able to even yeah
put a few words together much less right
and deliver a comment like that that was
off the cuff in fact before the brain
surgery Rodney you know was having like
a heart to heart with me and he said you
know I don't know maybe I won't be able
to even be in Show Business uh after the
brain surgery who knows I don't know
what I'll do
um because I'm too jealous to be your
pimp
it is great and I think it's great and I
think like with and without revealing
too much I think like this is the only
time I'm like hey Tech billionaires
neuralink like we do want to figure out
how to preserve the brains uh like how
do we yeah when someone's at their best
we lose them true and it's like and and
like and I'm the first to criticize Tech
and putting you know computers in our
eyeballs but I'm like if we can why are
people these like it's it's to me it's
like I just lost both my parents and I
in general I grieve harder at the loss
of these great minds that we haven't
preserved these brains and we're not
protecting the great Comics brains I've
watched people's brains degenerate in
front of me but both my parents had
Strokes I'm watching my friends lose
their parents to alzheimer's like these
great we're preserving cars better than
like
you know a an overrated comedian's
Porsche is preserved better than
the brain of someone's mother like so
we're preserving the wrong things did uh
did Rodney ever like um like because you
know it took him a long time to find
that amazing success and I know that you
know
um did he feel like um with with these
crowds because he I remember seeing him
to a very young crowd and they loved him
did he did he feel like he was relevant
to them or did he even understand what
they thought was funny about that or did
he think that it was just like you know
Funny's funny because there really is
now like you know it's almost like you
know depends on which way the wind blows
in terms of like what a crowd gets what
a crowd does and you know
popularity transcends Generations
the mix and the crowd would be
died in the audience one night
um you know from laughing and had a
heart attack right there and someone had
a heart attack yeah and died yes got the
young Jam Grand yes I was there then I
went out and sold the family while
Rodney continued to perform but my point
is to in addition to you know the grain
market he had maybe even a more uh you
know predominance of the younger people
if there would be college kids who
couldn't afford to get a room who would
come with their backpacks and they would
line up in front of the um the Hollywood
Theater door
um just waiting for him to come on stage
so it was amazing
20s
was taken to see uh one of Rodney's
shows when he was 13.
that's great wow
um well I have one other question
that's awesome
it was before I think it was
or something and
saw that there were all young people
there it's just young people were there
to see Rodney wow you know and sometimes
the audience would do really great
things like to show that they didn't
respect him
one night I think it was in the 80s I
was there as well but they all brought
newspapers so they'd be sitting in the
audience reading a newspaper you know as
a little joke that's so funny
hey y'all
sick of smelling like Wharf
can't stand smelling like trout want to
smell better naked they wait till I tell
you about Lumi whole body deodorant for
pits privates and Beyond and by Beyond
you know what I'm saying Lumi was
created by an OB GYN who just
what a concept a product being made by a
doctor
instead of a podcaster
this OB GYN discovered improved in
clinical testing that the vagina is not
to blame for day-to-day odor below the
belt so she developed Lumi a uniquely
formulated ph balanced deodorant it's
aluminum free skin safe and clinically
proven to control odor for up to 72
hours okay so check this out
Lumi whole body deodorant first of all
the toasted coconut is my favorite it
smells oh my God it smells so good
you're just gonna smell like a delicious
like snow cone I put it under my armpits
yes yes but I also put it under my boobs
because that is a crevice that sweats a
lot because we all know Mommy doesn't
wear bras very often okay so that one is
like a um like a deodorant stick like
you normally use but this one is like a
cream that you can kind of just like rub
everywhere which is kind of a miracle I
take this one on planes with me unlike
some deodorants that try to mask odors
with a fragrance Lumi is formulated and
powered by mandelic acid to stop odor
before it starts more like a pre
deodorant it's aluminum free baking soda
free trash free paraben free pH balance
for a safe use below the belt choose
from a variety of fresh bright scents
like clean Tangerine that one I actually
someone took from my house I'm actually
pissed because I haven't had the clean
Tangerine yet I love the lavender Sage
tasted coconut I actually want to eat it
I wonder if you can
um anyway
lumi's starter pack is perfect for new
customers it comes with a solid Stick
deodorant which I'm holding right now
cream tube deodorant which is just so
darling this packaging uh and two free
products of your choice like a mini body
wash and deodorant wipes new customers
get five dollars off a Lumi starter pack
with code Whitney at lumide.com that
equates to over 40 percent off your
starter pack when you visit lumide.com
and use the code Whitney guys don't
sweat it gals don't stink it time to not
smell like grocery store sushi for no
reason thank you Lumi hold on Dave had
one other question and I have one other
microphone now I'm really getting in
because we're because sorry Dave they've
had another question there's a little
bit of a delay you guys uh uh yes in my
emotional development and mental but
also in this wi-fi situation uh what's
happening is nothing short of a
technological Miracle so if you complain
about the Wi-Fi connection
um I hope Joe Rogan hunts you with a bow
and that you die in Cold Blood so Rodney
was so good to the young I guess you
could call it the Next Generation Comics
you know the the kinesins and the Dom
iraras and the Bill Hicks he's open to
Comedy Club and Roseanne Barr all these
different people when he gave him the
tap saying like you know you're going to
be on my on my special that was that he
made their careers and I always like
that about it it looked like he really
enjoyed doing that like he really
enjoyed these people make me laugh I
want everyone to see you know it's it's
nature nurture whatever I know we grew
up we all have the scarcity complex like
I'm now now that my parents have passed
I'm able to put together pieces of when
my you know when food would hit the
table uh Weaver Chicken McNuggets would
hit the table my sister and I would lick
them
to basically claim the Nuggets you know
like scary when you grow up without so
it's like comedians I think were
uniquely
um we have very intense scarcity
complexes and then we get into comedy
and then we go you know I can't we can't
share there's you know there's 4 000
theaters in America more more I'm sorry
I just made that number up leaders yeah
there's tons we can't possibly do every
one every night right and we're jealous
when other people other Comics succeed
some of them some of them I I always
feel that like it's it's you know
especially like we were talking about
joke writing when somebody knows how to
write a joke you you want to hear more
jokes because it's just like so hard to
actually write one and for one to
actually work in front of a crowd so
when somebody can do that or if there's
somebody who's interesting and different
and like you definitely want to see it
and with the younger Comics you know
maybe there is like uh nowadays there's
so many ways for them to actually
platform themselves so it's not really
that same kind of uh experience but I
always gave that to Rodney I was like
man everybody on his shows are like so
funny and they all went on to incredible
success and that was really because of
him but it really always looked like
when he did those shows that he wasn't
phoning it in he really enjoyed it I'm
realizing
because the eye for talent was unmatched
he could tell like yeah he probably
because if somebody had it or didn't
have it one time
one time back to his General who
I'm kidding but comedians by the way and
I I met so many Rodney and I you know
oftentimes they'd be a group event over
at our place you know for dinner or
whatever I don't think I've ever met an
unintelligent comedian smartest people
like the infield world uh become
comedians that still won't test their
cocaine for fentanyl but yeah they're
brilliant but I was gonna say he also
was a connection to the old whose
connection to the old crew makes him a
laugh you know there's a little science
but you've got to surprise them uh you
know to get that you know action of
laughter I think what I'm realizing is
like
Rodney had discipline
yes and self-discipline is one of the
hardest things to do because we're our
own boss and normally you go to a job
and someone says you have to work you
have to produce this or you don't get
paid and like I'm really struggling
right now with self-discipline because
I I'm admitting it I'm I'm a phony I
feel like you you put you know you're
like you put the work in when it comes
to other people I can do it and I'm
finding I I feel Joy when I'm able to
lift another comic up in some way or
give them Joy like like Adele just came
on this podcast and I just all I want is
to make him laugh and bring him Joy
because who heals the healers who makes
who what makes what makes whatever but
but let me say something else it's not a
benediction I know you know what I mean
but but when Rodney came off stage
because now I'm a little bit worried
when I come off stage and and get the
laughs I've worked so hard to earn
I don't I I go ugh you you fucking ha
you should have fucking done this you
should like well we all do that we all
yeah did he come off the time I get joy
is when I see someone else sore yeah
another comic store or have a
breakthrough or be brave and but did
Rodney come off stage and ever be like
nailed it or was he like
seldom he would listen to the recordings
after you know it was trying out
material and so on and then sometimes
he'd want to turn right around real back
because he would think of a way of of
improving a joke and wanted to see if he
was right or not he never liked took his
own judgment for it never took mine
um you know he would almost went back
and he had to hear it from the from the
crowd that was his barometer of success
there and um you know and I believe
Louis Anderson said something in an
interview which is so true is that
Rodney would take a perfectly good joke
and then try to make it better and this
I guess is it's discipline too to just
caring that much
um he wanted to just keep pruning and
keep pruning it you know I think today I
think today you get shamed for that so
when I try to make a joke great people
go you have OCD I had a psychiatrist
psychiatrists are trying to put me like
I was put on Prozac they're like you
need to be on medication people are
trying to put me on Adderall because
they're like you're so obsessive that
joke's already great why are you working
hard obsessing yeah it's obsessive but
is that bad or is it I think I don't
think genius mind but you do yeah
Whitney curlings believe me
creates Perfection and that you want to
keep going and there's a desire and urge
a compulsion mean to continue
um perfecting and perfecting and then
you get the result of that is that look
around you jack a little bit four
decades later I mean there are still
people raffling at that
um at his you know through a second jobs
he's by the way because he he was built
for Twitter I mean he was doing his
jokes he he his jokes were tweets so
true before Twitter existed
and and a tell does this and so does
Rodney you're giving people the gift of
when I when people sell merch I'm kind
of like I don't want to sell merch my
job is to give you the gift of being the
funniest person at the office the next
day I need to give you a couple jokes
you can repeat that work yeah and then
I'm gonna make it so you can kill it
work Comics we don't steal each other's
jokes but everyone here the idea is you
go home with some jokes that you can
tell tomorrow and be the funniest person
on your date you can go you have you can
flirt with a girl because you say
so my dad I grew up watching my dad use
Rodney danger
I grew up my body
I grew up watching my dad use Rodney
Dangerfield jokes on waitresses oh yeah
well I'm telling you he was he would
like that he was part of the national
like you know it was it was like we we
were all a part of it but the one big
compliment I'll give because I even
really so nice but generous with your
time sorry thank you sorry I know you
have to go Joan I'm being so selfish is
that uh you know not to make it all
about comedy is that uh doing a um doing
a Tonight Show or um any of these TV
spots where it's all to time and it's
not it's not really uh it's not really a
fun experience of where like you
basically hit a mark and you look in the
camera and there's an audience there
that's cold cold and they're like
basically waiting and and for him to
like kind of like you could tell like
just how many of those has he's done
like the Carson's he must have done 50
60 I mean I can only imagine how many he
did
70 of the arson shop and I don't
remember 35 of Jay Leno and and so on
but it was so important that when the
Carson show was the most important thing
for sure for sure it was it was it was
the it was the ultimate but he he he was
able every time to nail it and like even
though like I've done Letterman's and
lenos and all those all those different
things and I think today's generation
Comics they season they go what do you
get out of that but that was the thing
that really helped you book clubs it
also told everybody who said you know
what are you going to do with your life
that's what you're doing so but but the
most important thing was thank you for
saying it's a lot of it's so much work
and so much stress to do that to take
what you would do in a club over an hour
and and condense it down to the whatever
standards in practice uh would allow you
to do for the six to eight minutes and
he would do long he would go six hard
seven hard standing and then he would
panel for two breaks so that's another
for him that was probably another 30 40
jokes so whenever we do an appearance
he's probably looking at 50 60 70 punch
lines and that's like more than I can
say that it's probably more than I have
in my act right now so that's amazing
that he was able to do that over and
over and over and over again so he
really had to train for it
with no I the way that I memorized like
my special I called it jokes because I
went I'm going to do jokes jokes yeah no
fat zero I want to just experiment with
this thing where a comedian just tells
jokes and if if other Comics think I'm
corny if you think I'm hacky if you
think I'm mainstream fine I'm just gonna
do what I'm paid to do and just tell
jokes and um uh and I would do voice
memo that because my brain is I'm so
dyslexic like like learning it like I'll
record it on voice memo listen back to
it so I go these one one-liners I I the
only reason I'm able to remember it all
because is I'm able to visualize it in
thread did he have a system of how he
remembered it all
hey rape Corbin all of the jokes and on
a little um tape recorder that he would
get a Radio Shack and then he would
listen to it over and over and over
again and he would stop it rewind and
yeah and that's that was his number okay
so we do the same because I can't read
um
because also it's like you don't realize
how much fat you're adding on stage when
you're up there because I realized that
I remember Pat when I was like I say you
know you know anyway you know yeah yeah
and I'm like I didn't even realize I say
you know 40 times in an hour it's trash
yeah it's nervous ticks anyway you know
so anyways you know what I'm doing and
it it's the it could be the difference
between a laugh and an Applause break
yes you know and and the little things
like when you realize that you're
talking for an hour and every everything
that you're talking about happened last
week yeah so last week I was on the
slide so last week I was at this and
you're like busy week you know like just
the little ways that you have to one
word will throw the audience and also
the things you visualize like I think
that that people have so little respect
for what because we make it look easy
you know and I think that it's like
people because we make it look easy
people think it's easy okay then why are
comedians killing themselves with a
doorknob right hanging themselves you
know what I'm saying then why do we hang
ourselves with on a doorknob and
so to me it's like the amount of work
that goes into should I say this word or
this word uh because our job is to make
sure everyone is thinking the same thing
at the same time and having the same
image in their head so for example
there's this joke there's this joke I
was working on to get everyone to have
the same image at the same time
especially with how fractured everything
is now like worth it means something
different to everyone now so I was doing
this joke uh about like for my the last
special the whole thing was like people
think technology is dangerous
um you know uh people video games are
dangerous whatever you think that's
dangerous we played with matches like
growing up we played with matches right
right but every but it would kill but
then sometimes it wouldn't and it'll
kill and sometimes it wouldn't and I was
like fascinated I was like why is this
such a Mercurial joke why is this so
unpredictable and someone finally had
the kindness a fan or who not my fan I
don't believe in and it was like my fans
they're comedy fans they go see they go
see people too they don't and um he said
I just want to tell you something when I
think of a match I think of it not
lighting oh oh interesting everybody has
a different image so he goes I don't
think matches are dangerous at all
because they never like for me you know
and so I was like oh my God there's
different kinds of matchbooks oh wow
some of them light some of them don't
and that's on me it's arrogant to go
everyone is picturing the same book of
matches that I picked because I picture
one that's lighting and you throw in a
fire that's dangerous you know so it was
like
and then all the way down to
we stick ours put our fingers in light
sockets and then uh uh someone
in a rural Richmond show went well we
didn't have electricity so the light
sockets actually weren't ever dangerous
oh wow you know so it's like that's how
everybody's own experience affects them
that's how like specific we have to be
because like when you we go down to town
and we go we have a joke about this uh
something something Steakhouse and then
we have to go is it Ruth Chris is the
Palm what's the fanciest Steakhouse here
I need the reference to work for
everyone because if I say what's the
local grocery stores at Safeway is it
Food Lion is it is it uh Publix is it
whatever because if I say they're on
grocery store for this joke the whole
rest of my sets fucked oh yeah yeah and
they think I'm they think I'm just like
a robot coming in that doesn't know
their town and they hate me because I
went like so and next time you know when
I go to the Giant and they they're
saying they have only a Safeway in their
town and I've said Giant and they're
like wait a second you've broken the
spell that you're their friend or that
you know them and now you're just this
Hollywood asshole so it's like it's like
Rod yeah the internet thing is gone with
it exactly or the what's your grocery
store what's the store you guys go to
like that's what we started doing in a
way and I was like when did we stop
caring about the audience's experience
and making them do our work for us and I
look at how hard Rodney worked on these
details and it makes me have less shame
because everyone diagnoses me as you're
a workaholic you're too ambitious you
work too hard and I'm like I don't think
you can take other people's time too
seriously yeah
that was at the time maybe eight million
people or so he wanted all new people
watching to laugh at the same time and
to get the jokes you know so it's to use
responsibility and and you know you have
to have to try out the material in order
to be assured that it was going to uh
work its magic and I don't know any
advice of not knowing I mean you've got
how you do it well just one more thing
about like his Tonight Show because I I
know this is like we can keep you here
for hours and you're being very kind to
like feel these questions but when he
would sit with Johnny and that's the
ultimate you know like you you've made
it and Johnny would um basically set him
up because that's what they want to know
like a lot of people know this now but
it would be like you know so um I hear
you've been um you know um you've been
on the road a lot so and then you would
tell your joke so it looked like you're
having like a conversation so I could I
I could see with with Rodney he had it
all planned out and if Johnny didn't do
it the way he was supposed to he would
be like a little upset like all right uh
you know I the next joke is supposed to
be this and you're kind of jumping ahead
in the in the in the conversation and he
wasn't like free form like that he
basically knew what he wanted to do on
both the stage and then also on the
couch whereas for me I'd be like great
let's wait whatever you want to talk
about something else besides what we
planned on that would be so awesome you
know but let's go take a risk and jump
off a cliff but but I don't like the
challenge of that but I like also like
you said his focus and his discipline is
something that you know you can never
get enough of it yeah I think his point
was hey buddy we have a job to do we can
fuck around and improvise backstage but
these people paid money to see the thing
that we prepared right we don't get to
we don't get to be the head chef at the
best restaurant in the world and
screw around and I think that's I think
that I I'm Rodney Rodney that the way
you are thinking about that as well and
like if Johnny brought up the wrong Pew
or whatever Rodney took control back by
saying uh not yet right something like
that and and it would become funny that
he did that right and go right back to
like yet another joke about health or
getting old or something like that I
mean Rodney is stuck to certain things
here and there
um you know but he would get control
back and he had the confidence to do
that you know
um and and uh and Johnny didn't run I
mean it just it worked it all it only
worked but I think there's an
embarrassment uh Comedians and so on
I'll speak for myself I think there's a
little bit comedians who are a little
embarrassed these days to be prepared
you know it's like it's like we're
embarrassed to try too hard well I'm
fulfilled coining now with all these
jokes I'm telling and I play the
recorder as well so I mean honestly I'm
like I'm just like why do I hate myself
for writing a perfect joke and then
writing it I'm like oh God everyone's
gonna think I'm such a hack for writing
and delivering that perfect joke like
we're a little bit comedies in this
place where it's like well why don't you
tell a long boring story about you know
that may or may not pay off at the end
um it's a little bit of a like the
sharing you're delivering it and if your
persona is strong enough I mean people
people think even the material is true I
mean Rodney used to get that all the
time people thought his jokes he would
laugh at that later say yeah they think
you know the dog comes to my leg you
know all that stuff
um but but that's with anything I mean
that comes into it is you know delivery
what what did can I ask one more thing
Time Warner um so everyone whoever Q
Anon that storm the capital can you
please all collude to storm Spectrum
Wi-Fi like start storming the right
corporate like for destroying the uh
this internet connection
you have a 12 room house with a 1G uh
wireless system here
I mean we're basically in a farmhouse
that's where we are right now we're like
ding ding the dinner bell and let's
bring in The Hired Hands your house is
so wonderful it's a training I keep
thinking about it by the way the only
reason like I only know I've made it in
any way when Joan says like something
that I have she likes I'm like oh I've
made it also my favorite thing about
Joan is that when I first met her she
brought me uh a gift that was uh she
faced little capsules of face cream made
of
salmon come salmon oh yes is it called
is it called delicious
it's salmon it's salmon semen is that
right
it did she goes this is this I go why
why do you look you know like um Gallade
Maxwell would traffic you to an island
is how young you look so I was like so I
was like why do you
um look so young and she brought me the
capsules she used it's for they're from
South Korea salmon come capsules
just shut up
left
the red has caught on now and and it's
just it's really hard to pick up things
now but yeah they're Treasures I share
the treasure with you and I because you
deserve that you're so amazing but you
know and I appreciate you so much and
we're gonna um go to um I'm dragged
kidnapping her and bring her to Austin
with me to bring something of Rodney's
for uh Joe's Club to put in the green oh
that's great that's really cool to put
something in the green room so we're
trying to figure out what to do exactly
and then and then by the way this is my
favorite I was like okay we need to find
a date that's special to Joe Rogan
because she's like oh well let me find a
Tonight Show that's like happened on
Joe's birthday that's Rodney's or
something cool special and I was and
then I called Joe's wife and I was like
what's your wedding anniversary maybe we
could do it as like if there was a
Tonight Show on your wedding anniversary
and I didn't even know this or maybe I
just repressed it Joe's wedding Joe got
married on Halloween
if that's not if that's that makes a lot
of sense if that's not the most stand-up
comedian shit he's like I have gigs
booked every weekend I have to be at
like you know Penguins now we the only
time to get married is on Halloween
that's the only night we have open
because you can't because you can't do
stand-up on Halloween that'll be so cool
first of all I love that Joe does what
he does and that he's building that club
I I've been hearing about for three
three years now two and a half years I
can't wait to see it in person it's
gonna be awesome do you want to come on
Monday I wish I could I gotta go up to
uh blah blah I gotta go up to my gigs
but can you but this Monday we're going
to do kill Tony at the uh my mom you
know oh yep yep I got it I've been there
now for 10 days so and then but it's
gonna open it's gonna be huge it's gonna
be comedy fans it's going to be super
fans and it's also going to be a great
spot for Comics it's like this is like
clubs open and close all the time but
this is one that like it's it's
definitely there's gonna be nothing like
it and like Rodney like most comedy
venues or in clubs certainly are not
um and this is part of the reason I
wanted to do the roasts even though I
didn't it destroyed me in a way my mom
was in home hospice while I was making
the roasts yeah you really because I
went comedians are the only people that
should be in charge of deciding how
comedy clubs should be designed how they
should be run but we don't want to run
businesses we don't want to be
responsible for shrimp going bad in a
refrigerator we don't want to be have
employees we're not designed to have an
HR department so so comedy clubs are
usually designed by people that aren't
Comics you know and and comedy shows are
run by people who aren't comics and then
you have a bunch of people that went to
uh school for advertising telling us
what is and isn't funny so I I'm putting
myself in a situation where I'm like I
guess I have to run the roast because
all right no one you know what I'm
saying will protect us but Rodney did
that too Rodney started his own club in
New York and it was designed
you know that is a classic venue but
remember it was like you could Pace back
and forth because we Pace a lot of these
comedy clubs they put you in a like a a
like in a hula hoop you have the hula
hoop to move and we pay I Pace like a
panther because we're zoo animals we're
lions in the zoo and we're pacing pacing
and the way you know so Joe's designing
this to accommodate comedians instead of
um you know whatever businessmen usually
design clubs for it's going to be
there's going to be nothing like it
that's all I can say and uh thanks so
much for uh talking to us and this is
always a great surprise so thank you
Whitney this is great it's a great
surprise to me that um I the the
Spectrum uh that I have to go to court
with Spectrum next week because I paid
them for a hard line in here well
and I'm on the Spectrum as well so it's
hard enough it's hard enough for me to
read the social the the facial cues
with me I didn't know that I knew I
think Rodney was too I was diagnosed
with autism a bunch as a kid but I beat
it but also all those diagnoses I think
it's like it's very hard you know it's
like I work with kids that are cool
autistic now with Equine Therapy and
it's like very the
um being traumatized as a child uh has
the same
um I don't want to say masquerades
because that's going to sound for sure
it
autism presents itself the same way as a
kid who's traumatized a kid who's been
abused a kid that is like shy like they
all kind of present so when you go like
oh this kid's autistic like you know I
was also had a severe sexual abuse and
stuff too so and and neglect people you
know they're now showing like neglect in
a lot of ways I'm not saying it's worse
than being um uh abused it's
um you know embarrassing to like you
know not be the one that was picked by
the priest it's a little bit it's like a
rejection or whatever but being but
neglect you have your own internal world
and you don't learn to be socialized so
I was kind of like Fair it's a huge
impact Ronnie was no better ball
um
writing verbal like verbal I'm not good
at speaking believe it or not like
that's why jokes are like I I think in
terms of jokes and I think that
something Rodney has all Comics that I
love have is when you hear a word right
there's a role so when Rodney said um he
heard the word cough
right most people think cough but we
have a Rolodex that goes cough means a
lot of different things we're going to
go to the third definition in Webster's
not the first so so I think that's the
difference between Comics so so we you
go um you're coughed something up we're
gonna go yeah we're gonna go to the
third definition in Webster it's not the
first everyone's gonna go to the first I
don't hear when I hear cough I don't
hear
that so Comics I'm repeating myself
because if someone doesn't tell me to
stop talking anymore
wow so so I never I never heard the same
thing everyone else heard and I and we
don't see the things everyone else sees
that's interesting so like people were
probably you know not to keep it going
on and on but sorry they probably you
know it's always like the guy on stage
and the guy off stage there was a he was
quiet he was a little shy correct like
uh you know maybe offstage it wasn't
like he's like like uh you know uh like
in the movie you know like like where
he's like let's party you know he's just
like basically uh because my regular a
regular dude and that's always
disappointing because my thing is I have
something funny and interesting to say
but if you guys are talking and
distracting me I can't get it out so I
need to get security guards to tell
everyone to shut up so that I can get it
out because I get overwhelmed and I like
and I need to rehearse it a lot you know
because I also had a speech impediment
so I would have to like rehearse it so
that's why I was like I'm not good in
conversation it's like remember Memento
I'm not good on the phone you know it's
like I think we get famous and known for
how good we are at talking but people
people don't know how much work went
into being able to say it publicly
and then I think I've tricked people
into believing I'm really good at
talking but like all the stuff you've
seen I've like practiced and practiced
and practiced and that's the only reason
it came out I look like I'm good at it
do you think you should go on stage with
somebody behind you holding this up like
it's your Ten Commandments and then they
if the crowd sucks you just smash it and
like you you you have uh defiled can I
tell you what you did
so so can I tell you the most traumatic
and then and then we I will let everyone
go and stop imprisoning them
um uh so the top of that set see how
he's he wrote great crowd with two
exclamation marks Rodney Dangerfield see
at the top I didn't see that great crowd
two exclamation points okay so top top
left of that yep do you see it up left
left keep going clear see down
yep to your right a bit sorry I'm so
dyslexic do you see that it says do you
say it says great crowd do you see that
no oh yeah I see it great crowd great
crowd he wrote great crowd with two
exclamation marks so
sorry
go ahead that was him like Hey you're a
great crab but he wrote it out yeah one
of the most traumatic moments of my life
and I've been
molested by hitchhikers that were like
one of the most traumatic moments of my
life and I did stand up on last call
with Carson Daly one of the most
traumatic moments of my life was Dove
Davidoff
a comedian New York guy now back that's
me and my horse yeah do you want to hold
up a picture of my horse one
um calming image maybe keep the go ahead
is I had written out I was going to do
the Brea Improv and I'd written my jokes
out to try to memorize them you know and
uh and I and and Dove David off like got
in my car a friend of mine and just like
picked up my set list just to screw with
me and was like I was like I have to go
to Brea I have to go to Brea to do this
set I was this I was only been doing
comedy maybe like four years and he
picked up my PR he's like oh you print
out your jokes like we were just messing
around and he grabbed the jokes and he's
like you write out your jokes you dork
and then he looked at him and the top
line was
what's up Brea question mark he goes
what's up Breya he's like you had to
write this out like you you were worried
you'd forget that and I was like so
embarrassed it was like one of the most
embarrassed I've ever been but like sure
enough sometimes I'm in Brea and I say
Irvine or sometimes like one of the
Ontario let's name the whole Chain by
the way you and then you go wherever the
fuck I am and if you do that you you're
dead for the rest of the set you're dead
if you say if you're in Brea and you say
wear my Irvine Brea is disrespect you
know and I just wanted so badly to not
go into someone's have someone pay money
to see me disrespect their Town yeah and
I was like and then I was like wait a
second and then seeing that set made me
proud to be a dork it made me proud to
be a nerd that works hard yeah and if
Comics think I'm lame like okay but like
they don't you guys don't pay money to
come see this I mean this is it this
might be a bad analogy but like seeing
the setlist it's like getting to hold
Lincoln's acts you know what I'm saying
I mean it's just like historic
so it's like yeah it's just like I think
Rod like studying Rodney makes me go oh
maybe I don't have to be on all these
meds that these psychiatrists want me to
be on because I work hard yeah I know
you're fine you know what I mean Joan
you Jones I love you if you're in New
York come by the comedy seller please
also what's it like to know that Hitler
wouldn't have killed you
there's the bathroom here
oh yeah I love you Joan thank you for
letting us Ambush you for the beach well
thank you thank you so we're gonna work
out we're gonna work out flights to to
go to Austin
um and we were just recording this
podcast and and Rodney just came up
because
um a tell was talk tell was talking
about how someone a comic just said you
know if you have too many jokes per
minute you know you're like like less
jokes per minute is better now or
something and he him and I were
commiserating about it and I went no no
no
like and I pulled Rodney's set and I was
like this is the this is the gold
standard and anyone that is trying to
lower the jokes per minute for an
audience is just being lazy and
uh like
this like I just want to remind everyone
like this is what we're supposed to be
doing
oh thank you Rodney with it and
appreciated someone like I'm not I'm not
being elegant in the way that I'm saying
this but I'm just like
you know this is why comedy fans are
upset because people comedians aren't
doing comedy anymore for them they're
lecturing them how to vote they're
they're not honoring their time they're
disrespecting their time they're showing
up unprepared they think a lot of
comedians think if I'm just on stage and
being authentic like I'm
uh that's not what they're paying to see
they're paying to see a surgeon do
surgery
they're they're paying to see a
Craftsman do their craft and
I just needed that reminder
um and I think everyone needs that
reminder
I agree that the kind of people that
paid it that pay to see comedy need to
laugh and we're tricking people into
coming to comedy venues and we're like
Hey we're gonna make you laugh and then
you get in their seats and then we
lecture them how to vote
I missed I missed out I kind of tuned
out after the salmon semen uh treatment
I love you Joan oh oh I just hung up on
you
okay well that was so what a great treat
thank you you know who gets less respect
than Rodney Dangerfield his widow Poor
Joe you know who truly gets no respect
um before first I said your dad I still
I was like whoa just blew me away how
great she looks
unbelievable yeah awesome right so she
lives out here right that's what it
looks like if you
um laughter is the best not only
medicine but the best Dermatology
amazing I love you so much thank you
Whitney I think about you a lot I hope I
always help good things for you so ditto
ditto ditto we both don't sleep you can
always call me at the middle of the
night I'll be up I love you bye
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Applause]